the first step to achieving a massive
dream is Conquering tiny impulses
I think it's exactly what we were
talking about earlier it's like if you
like
I I got a there's a a tweet that I may
actually you
you were the one who made it go viral
right uh which was uh when you quoted me
quoting you to David Gogan yeah it's
just this endless Human Centipede of
[__] homozy quotes
um but he's like you don't you don't uh
you don't feel confidence by shouting
affirmations in the mirror but by
stacking
by having an undeniable stack of proof
that you are who you say thank you
without work yourself down thank you
I'll quote you to you which is a new a
new low
so so that right yeah
um a lot of people were like no but what
if you don't have any successes like how
do you get started and I still think
that the the quote is 100 valid it's
that they don't realize the validity of
the smaller things that they have done
up to that point and so it's being able
to transfer your successes of like okay
like did you get dressed this morning
like did you did you get in front of the
computer like you have evidence it's
smaller evidence but you have enough
evidence to make the claim that you can
do this and then you do that enough
times that you have enough evidence to
make a claim that you can do this and
support it and I think um that's where
the
big outcomes come from lots of of
constrained tiny impulses they're saying
like you know what I'm going to get this
tiny Victory and I know how to say no to
that I noticed a hair say no to heroin
today or whatever yep um that would be a
hard one you know a lot you're implicit
probably larger
um but that's the idea is just stacking
as many of those
pieces of evidence that give you proof
that you are who you say you are that
you can you have done what you say you
can do yeah it's uh
the the challenge of action or belief
first is something that I've been
playing around with so much and my
friend James he wrote a book uh the c
word like confidence it was a book about
how to be confident right and um I do
feel like a a big footnote summary could
have been that quote from you and the
problem is this is something that I've
seen as well a good example coming from
a world where I was successful in
business before I was successful
personally
um I have a skill set now and my
capacity within this particular skill
set and the performance of what that
does are intrinsically linked right
there's almost a linear relationship as
I become better at networking with
guests with recording with doing all of
the other things the show increases when
I run a business there were so many
degrees of freedom between my inputs to
the business and the success of the
business that someone with like
malignant imposter syndrome could always
explain away how things had gone well so
I would say oh it's because we timed the
market right oh it was because of like
this member of staff that we brought in
I mean I trained him but really he would
have been great without me or whatever
and um self-doubt can sort of wheel its
way in in very sort of Nefarious ways
when you do that
um then switching to something where you
have a relatively undeniable stack of
proof even undeniable to the part of you
that wants to deny proof right which is
that imposter syndrome
after a little while it's just a
crushing weight that you cut I call it
imposter adaptation so you know if you
continue to disprove your imposter
syndrome in the real world and it
persists you have to admit to yourself
that it's got nothing to do with your
capabilities and everything to do with
your addiction to feeling like an
imposter this is just a trend of how you
think about the world you're looking for
competent you have competence without
confidence which is a lack of belief and
confidence without competency
self-delusion right so you need to have
this balance between the two but people
when they say well surely bill
self-belief becomes before action I'm
like well not particularly not if that's
not your nature I don't think like
you're asking for delusion there and it
is significantly easier for you to think
I am a fitness person if you just went
to the gym and did 10 push-ups then I am
a fitness person when I go to the gym
tomorrow and do 10 push-ups like where's
the show me spit and sawdust where's the
[__] reality of this you know
I agree good
opportunities only look like
opportunities in the rear view mirror
today they look like Risk how does
someone get around this this
um asymmetry between the fact that in
retrospect it seemed totally obvious and
yet the thing that you're looking at
right now looking forward you go that
might not be obvious in retrospect again
it's tough because um
a lot a lot of the big wins you're like
like Uber's the classic example right
like let's start a business where
strangers pick up girls who are 16 you
don't even drive them to their friends
houses like that sounds like a terrible
idea right like it just it but in
retrospect you're like no it'll be
totally fine because there's going to be
a mutual rating system and blah blah
blah right taking out the fact that
there are people who've been captured
and whatever what we'll put that to the
side right
um and the thing is is like just because
we're on the investing side what we
found is that there are always reasons
to say no to a deal
you can always find reasons to say no
because there's nothing that's risk-free
even treasuries have risk the U.S
economy could collapse and treasury
should be worth nothing like and you
could create a really compelling
argument lots of influencers spent a lot
of time doing that right
um is it likely maybe I don't know but
it's probably less likely than than a
bank failing because if the US fails all
the banks by default are also failing so
which one you know which of these is
greater risk so then it gets then you
start comparing risks rather than trying
to eliminate risks and so if we're
looking at opportunities that's why I
like Risk adjusted return is one of the
things that a lot of investors look at
which is like is there a way that I can
appropriately adjust this risk to
normalize different opportunities and I
think that that single skill set is
one of if not the most important
important skill sets as an entrepreneur
because fundamentally it's betting like
that's what we're doing we're making
bets every day we bet with our time
without their money
um with the limited constraints we have
or limited resources we have against
unlimited opportunities
because that's the hard part is that
there is unlimited women in the red
dress now there's some fours and there's
some sixes and there's some eights but
you have to both rate the girl right the
opportunity and then also how crazy is
she right or whatever you know whatever
risk factor you want to you know
associate with this is she going to stab
me in my sleep I don't know right does
she have a crazy ex-boyfriend I don't
know about I don't know right and so
that's why we do the diligence process
but like the
the way that we because I just just tied
up this chapter in the book that's
coming out is when we're organizing
opportunities that we're going to pursue
with a business we look at what are the
ones that we have the absolute highest
likelihood of success that we have we we
need no new skills and no new effort if
we can do that or the least amount of
new effort and no new skills that would
be the first thing we're going to do and
then once we take off all the ones that
take basically no effort and no extra
skills we're like okay which ones take
more effort and still no skills and then
once we do that then we're like okay now
we can start learning a new skill and of
the different skills that we could learn
which of these is going to give us the
highest leverage as in most output for
the least amount of input and that's
pretty much how we tick down which of
these opportunities we want to pursue
because those have the lowest likelihood
of not happening
does this work in the personal world as
well the school is an investor that
isn't in business that's just thinking
about life opportunities do I want to
learn to salsa dance or code I think
that the investor frame
is a is is simply people who have been
scored and Quantified on their ability
to make decisions and so I think that we
can learn a ton from how investors make
decisions overall it's like why Ray
dalio's book principles became like a
bestseller even though 99.9 of people
reading the book aren't even investors
or definitely not investors at his level
but the principles of good decision
making are just Quantified and we have a
scoreboard for these guys being
excellent decision makers whereas most
other people you don't have a real
scoreboard so we can't tell how valid is
their advice and I think that's what
makes uh taking advice from really
world-class investors who've been doing
it for decades
um as a great source of information
because we can validate that they have a
stack of undeniable proof that they are
who they say they are what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full
don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]